the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the 2021
u.s championships and u.s women's
championships as well as the hall of
fame induction for 2020 i am marissa
ashley it's my pleasure to be here on
this magical night what a gorgeous place
to host this event
it will be indeed very special for
the folks who will be inducted into the
hall of fame for sure and i'm sure that
the players are excited because last
year
everything was online and this year we
are back
to playing chess over the board
we have some of the finest players in
the nation here competing i always say
this is my favorite event to commentate
here in st louis because of the fire the
passion
the players giving it their all and
there's always amazing back stories so
we expect more of the same this year
well we do have a great venue and to
talk about the venue and
add a few remarks we'll be mike isaacson
who is the artistic director and
executive producer of the muni mike
[Applause]
good evening
on behalf of the board and all of us who
work here at the muni
we are so honored
to serve as your host for this evening
um it is
deeply exciting and moving uh my
relationship with the chess club in the
world chess hall of fame actually began
a few years ago because i live in the
neighborhood
and i've just been in awe of what
they've accomplished and seeing the
young people coming in and out and
seeing them play chess and over the last
couple years i've got to know them
individually personally
and what an extraordinary organization
and we are so proud to be hosting this
event that the connection i want to
focus on if you don't know anything
about the muni if you're
here from out of town is
um we are the oldest theater in the us
we just had our 104th season
uh just over there we have 10 000 seats
we have an extraordinary public access
program 1500 seats are free at night
and we host some of the world's greatest
talents on that stage
this room which i want to just honor the
chess club staff for making more
beautiful than i've ever seen it
um is actually a rehearsal platform
during the season
if you look at the dotted lines that are
beneath you those are stage marks where
things come in and out and the round
circle is our turntable but the really
amazing connection is in this space
in this space this is where people have
learned their craft
and their greatness
and their opportunity
which is what i've seen this
extraordinary organization do
in this space a future
tommy tune who went on to win nine tony
awards
choreographed his first musical
and when i look at what you're
accomplishing for young people and their
discovery talk to some slu students and
what they were accomplishing and how
exciting this is it is an incredible
gift to this community so as a partner
in this community i'm so grateful you're
here this is going to be an
extraordinary evening
and to dr jeannie karen singhfield and
rexenfeld if you don't know it you are
in a room of people who are so grateful
to you and what you've given and what
you've provided them so it is beautiful
to be here tonight where you're honored
great thank you
thank you for those words mike
well the hall of fame the world chess
hall of fame if you don't know if you
haven't been there you're missing out on
one of the great institutions in chess
they do a fabulous job of curating
setting up incredible exhibitions i
always am mystified by what they do
incredibly tonight
earlier today i should say for the very
first time i saw
an interview with bobby fisher
and bob hope from 1972 and surprisingly
bobby was really funny for one thing
more surprisingly
uh gary kasparov and fabiano caron is
sitting at the table with me had never
seen this interview either which is kind
of a shame that you have like
grandmasters who've never seen such an
epic interview
guys make sure you check it out at the
world chess hall of fame it's right on
the ground floor
as i said pretty funny stuff and in
charge of everything that happens the
magic at the world chess hall of fame is
its chief curator shannon bailey
[Applause]
um
after the dinner please come up and see
these beautiful
artifacts that are part of our permanent
collection all of them are named after
the
or produced by the sinful special genie
and her reading right chest and her
chest to go
on behalf of the entire staff of the
world chess hall of fame i want to
welcome you to this wonderful
celebration as well this night is so
special i love that we're finally all
here together it's such a great uh
evening to see all of you again
and i love that we're finally um
getting to induct jeannie and rex into
the
u.s chess hall of fame
congratulations to you both
i am also so happy to announce that this
past september did mark the 10th
anniversary of the world chess hall of
fame here in st louis
um all of that happened because of the
vision and the generosity of rex and
genie thank you again
um in these ten quick years we have
welcomed 138 000 visitors to the world
chess hall of fame
a 16 000 this year alone despite uh the
issues with the pandemics that's just
wonderful and we've shown 50 exhibitions
in that 10 years and we've had dozens of
concerts and lectures and programs all
of which have shown chess in a new and
exciting life
we are also able to do this under the
leadership of our great general manager
joy bray and the talent of our wonderful
staff
many of this staff has also been here
for 10 years with me doing all this so
that's incredible to have us all
together this long and we as maurice was
saying we do hope you come and visit not
only and see that great bobby fischer
video but our three exhibits that are
check please pawns and passports and
masterminds chess prodigies
we are going to have a big ten year
exhibition in january called mind art
experience 10 years of chess and culture
in st louis and that's going to open
like i said in january so come and come
back and see that
um i have been with the world chess hall
of fame since 2010 and i was also
involved with the chess club when it
opened in 2008 and you just knew that
something special was happening even
from the beginning
and that's truly like i said because the
vision of the stingfields each and every
induction to the hall of fame has always
been really special to um
to witness
but i love um experiencing the
celebration of each person who has made
this game so important um but uh seeing
genie and rex now joining the ranks of
these legends is so deserving and really
emotional for all of us who have been on
this journey so far
they are responsible for increasing the
love of this game in such a short time
and have given so many children artists
new players and lovers of culture two
unique and perfect
institutions
to easily fall in love with
i truly appreciate everything that they
have done for this game and everything
that they have done for st louis too and
i so look forward to what is yet to come
congratulations genie and rex
[Applause]
thank you for those words shannon
up next we have our great partners
at uss who had to give genie and rex
permission to take over the u.s
championship i'm sure they did it with a
giant smile on their faces
but to talk about what genie and rex
have meant to us chess is the vice
president of uss randy baum
so to say that rex and jeannie have
meant a lot to us chess is a huge
understatement
they are
clearly
the longest serving and largest
benefactors that u.s chess has ever had
and a lot of the success that u.s chess
has as an organization and many of its
best players is because of their active
involvement
and so i'm gratified to have the
opportunity to express our thanks to
both rex and jeannie tonight for their
enormous contributions to u.s chess
we we all understand the great
undertaking
that they do with the u.s championships
and this is i believe
the best
national chess championship in the world
and i think there are a lot of players
that would agree with that
but beyond that they have continued to
expand
their contributions to chess to include
the women's championship the junior
championship the girls championship and
now the senior championship and that
kind of expresses and explains their
interest in growing chess to all
segments over the population
i also should note that besides the
financial contributions they've made
which are many genie for example was
instrumental in obtaining the merit
badge for tess
with the boy scouts of america and
that's another example of how they have
expanded
what chess means in this country and
really appreciate that you know i had
the
fortune of having a small part of what
became
the involvement of st louis and the
sinfields in the u.s championship the it
goes back to 2008
i'm a director in a public finance firm
and it does a lot of work with the city
of st louis the city was interested in
doing a revenue study i direct the tax
policy practice in our firm
and so we were hooked up mayor slaves
chief of staff reached out to us and put
us in touch with rex's people
about the possibility that he might or
his non-profit associated with it might
fund that particular study so our
managing director and i came to st louis
we had tinner
anybody who's had dinner with rex knows
it was quite an experience
we uh we talked about a variety of
subjects we talked about public policy
we talked about politics baseball and
eventually the subject came around to
chess and i knew that rex was a chess
player i was at the time serving on the
executive board of u.s chess but i
didn't have any idea of exactly how much
rex was invested in our game and he told
me about this club that he was you know
building and i was like oh that's cool i
mean i've been to the 3ms the manhattan
marshall
and
mechanics chess clubs and i figured okay
this is going to be some something not
like that and i was blown away he took
me there we toured it
and it's a phenomenal facility it was
then and of course it still is and at
one point he said something along the
lines of you know maybe someday i'd like
to host a u.s championship and i'm not a
very good poker player so maybe rex
already knew that i was kind of pretty
interested in that being a possibility
and after that meeting the executive or
my managing director who is not a chess
player came out of that and said well we
may have not got a foul a funder for st
louis's revenue study but i think you
may have found a sponsor for the u.s
championship
and that was true
rex and the people in st louis have been
funding and founding and supporting and
holding that event ever since then from
2009 on
and um and it's a just an outstanding
event the thing that some people have
said to me is well that was kind of a
fortunate coincidence and i really don't
believe that because i believe
that at some point in time if it had not
been that first year rex would have been
founding funding and
building that u.s championship to what
it is now because that's kind of person
he is he's a visionary leader
and he knows how to brilliantly execute
on a vision
and as chess players that's kind of we
understand that as a combination that's
the way
you win in chess and that's the way
rex and jeannie have helped us bid
build a winning combination for us chess
and i'm so
happy to be a part right now
of their long overdue recognition as
members of the us chess hall of fame
thank you randy
[Applause]
well next up is a gentleman who's been a
visionary himself who's shown how to
execute at the highest level
and has been an amazing friend
to st louis and the singh fields
he may or may not have deserved to get
into the hall of fame
he probably did
got a couple of votes ladies and
gentlemen the 13th world champion of
chess
gary casparo
[Applause]
thank you
good evening
it's always delightful to be here in
saint louis
the chess capital of the world
[Applause]
no wonder i always feel
at home
with so many events
grandmasters and the beautiful chess
club and hall of fame
it reminds me a little of moscow in the
70s and 80s
except the weather
and food are better here
and there's not so much kgb around
i hope
the reason we are here tonight is also
the reason the
gateway cd has become
the gateway to chess
genie and rex sinful
their work
has not been mere sponsorship
as welcome as that
is in our sport
the advocacy for chess at every level
in every way
could only come
from a sincere passion for the game
and its many benefits
as a force for competition
education
and culture
there have often been arguments in the
chess world about whether to support the
grassroots
or the elites
do we emphasize chess in education and
use tournaments to build the next
generation
or do we host grand master tournaments
and support top players who in turn may
inspire the next generation of american
kids the way
bobby fischer's
victory did in 1972 nearly half a
century ago
perhaps
a better example these days the way the
fictional american champion beth harmon
has done
thanks to the success of netflix sheldon
quiz gambit
the only right answer
has been given by the sinfuls we do both
we do it all
and we see
what works best
we take action and move things forward
it's a very simple way to do things
in a very casual way too i must say
i knew from our first conversations
that rex didn't just want his name
on a building or a trophy
it was clear he wanted to do that most
important thing of all
to make a difference
to change lives
for the better
to change his city for the better
and through
those
lives
and this city to change the world for
the better
and there is no doubt
they have achieved it with much more to
come
from a beautiful chess club
to genie's tireless war creating the boy
scouts chess merit badge
to rex
early support of the rising stars junior
program
and hosting all the major u.s
championships
it's wonderful to see
how many of those talented chess kids
are now playing in the elite
championships and competing on the world
stage
others
have gone off to college
on to achieve in other areas
always with the confidence and skills
that chess gave them
each of them
owes a debt to the sinfuls
and this may be the only debt that rex
would never try to collect
this time his return on investment is
here with all of us
and here in the heart
i want to say a few words about
one of the heroes of the past that
because i think it's appropriate to
talk about this story
in the first half
of the 15th century
the small country of portugal became a
great exploring nation
much of the credit goes to a man who is
best known today simple as prince henry
dene miguel
or enrique on bagador
his keen interest in
charting and exploring the world did not
lead him personally out the ocean's blue
henry's legacy was to create schools
that taught the sciences
navigation
cartography and astronomy
he was the inspiration and patron of
journeys all over the known world
and beyond
henry's efforts would later form
universal lisbon
and laid the human foundation for
portugal to explore the globe and become
a world power
it started with the coast of africa the
madeira islands in 1419
considered the first territorial find in
what is now known as the age of
discovery
henry was not just trying to make the
usual 20
on these voyages
he wanted to push out into the unknown
to open the world to his people
to make
a difference
today in america we are living in a new
age of chess
thanks to the sinfuls and their passion
for making a difference
they are laying a solid human foundation
for the game of chess
and in the minds and souls of everyone
who is touched by their work
that boost in human capital is worse
more to gin anorex than any other kind
sending countless well-prepared
explorers out into the world
they have acted
out the jesuits saying
learn to give and to not count the cost
usually a hall of fame ceremony marks
the end of a great career
i think i might have a plaque or photo
in that building somewhere
as morris mentioned
but a career in promoting chess doesn't
have to end along with your hair
as much as genuine wrecks have achieved
they will not stop there
i'm honored to be here to induct them
into the u.s chess hall of fame
and i look forward with great
anticipation to seeing what they do next
congratulations my friends
[Applause]
thank you so much gary
before i introduce the next gentleman
who will take the stage and do
the honorary proceedings i'd like to say
just a couple of words
from a personal side
when i first came to st louis and i got
to meet
rex
it was a bromance right away
uh
some of you may know that
i like to once or twice
trash talk
a little bit a little bit but rex is one
of those that can give and take just as
well and i remember one of our dinners i
think it was at brass we were sitting
down outside and a waitress was trying
to get around rex
and he was kind of sitting basically in
her way and so i looked at her looked up
at her and i said
you know
please excuse him because he's so obese
and without skipping a beat rex said
please excuse him he just got out of
prison
and it's been a love affair ever since
you know i'll tell him about my yankees
how we won 27 world series we're the
best team ever and he'll say
yeah but you know that
the cardinals are 3-2 against the
yankees in the world series
and i got to deal with the nonsense
last thing i'll say though however is
after speaking with jeannie so many
times at dinner as well
hearing her incredible thoughts one
thing i can say rex is she's definitely
the smartest field
with that i will introduce to the stage
the vp of scholastic chess for u.s trust
and the chair of the scholastic council
sunil weirmantry
[Applause]
thank you maurice
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests
we have all heard about the renaissance
man
but how often does one speak of the
renaissance woman
dr jeanne cairns sinquefield
fits this bill to perfection
she's an academic
a polyglot
an accomplished bass player and lover of
music
and a noted philanthropist
and definitely not someone to mess with
after all
genie holds a black belt in judo
a fact that a beloved husband rex has
painfully experienced on a few occasions
i had the pleasure of getting better
acquainted with genie when my wife
carolyn and i
were guests of the sing fields at the
farm
one of the highlights of our stay was a
tour of the property
that jeannie took me on by golf cart
it was during this memorable ride that i
first learned about another one of her
passions
the boy scouts
i recall stopping at the lake house
jeannie told me how entire troops would
visit and conduct stem experiments there
and she planned to enhance their
experience by installing
state-of-the-art equipment for them
stem to chess was a logical
transition
genie went on to become a staunch
advocate for an idea that was first
advanced by ralph bowman a former chair
of the scholastic committee of u.s
stress
this was to create a chess merit badge
for the boy scouts
genie's dedication to the project soon
led to the realization of this dream
some years later the central west end
was treated to a live game of chess
in the shadow of the world's tallest
chess piece
on the street in front of the world's
best chess club and the world chess hall
of fame
and the pieces
the boy scouts naturally
the rest is history
today more than two hundred and fifty
thousand chess married badgers have been
awarded
[Applause]
it was during this period that dr
singfield began working on a pamphlet
entitled
learn to read and write chess
and i noticed
a few copies of them lying around i'm
sure you can pick one up on your way out
her academic background in linguistics
made her appreciate the value of
learning the language of chess
and she wanted to make this skill easily
accessible to everyone
she perfected the pamphlet with the help
of grandmasters affiliated with the
chess club
it has now been translated into a dozen
languages and may be downloaded free of
charge around the world
invaluable as these initiatives have
been to the world of chess
they're still pale in comparison to
genie's most significant contributions
the creation of the sinfield cup
and the cairns cup
it was on a sunny spring afternoon in
2013
that genie joy bray tony rich and i
were discussing the state of chess in
the country
genie remarked that despite all the
support rex was giving to u.s chess
there was no event bearing his name
thus was born the singfield cup
that fall the inaugural event was held
featuring four players the world
champion magnus carlson the number two
ranked player in the world leveronian
and the top two americans hikaru
nakamura and garakamsky
the sinfield cup has since evolved into
the crown jewel of the chess circuit
and is universally regarded as the
world's finest elite chess tournament
a few years later genie decided to
extend the same consideration to women
players
and launch the kerns cup
an invitational event that carries her
maiden name
unlike many other prestigious
international invitational tournaments
that are in danger of disappearing
the sink field cup and the kearns cup
are set up through the generosity of the
sink fields to continue long into the
future
[Applause]
their legacy is secure
therefore
with the lasting gratitude of chess
enthusiasts around the world
and with the authority vested in me as a
trustee of us of the u.s chess
trust i hereby induct dr jeannie kane
singfield
into the u.s chess hall of fame
[Applause]
so
this is a real honor to be inducted in
the world house hall of fame
given that i am
in this crowd and i am the only unrated
chess player
okay about you know rex and i moved back
to st louis
well actually missouri we live in the
farm but we have a house here
in 2006 and rex started talking about
starting a chess club and you know what
i thought
how expensive could it be
so it's it in two thousand
in eight or was it eight or nine
eight we started the chess club
and
we started sponsoring right after that
in 2009 the us chess championship and i
thought well that's fun
so we're talking my son owns a movie
studio
so i thought well we should
stream it right
get a couple of people and a camera or
whatever
instead we have the world's best
right slide who thinks that the
the stuff coming out of saint louis
is the best
live stream test
[Applause]
and then of course rex come to me and
says
of course this isn't going to be
expensive why don't we bring the world
chess hall of fame to st louis they'd
like us to do that
so i think okay
sounds okay right
we're gonna bring it and it was opened
and i thought okay
somebody was talking to me and said you
know how come we've never had chests of
the merit beds because everybody knows
i'm really big into scouts okay
so i called a friend of mine
and she was on the national committee to
approve new merit badges and she had a
hundred
that they looked at and she says chess
is the hundredth
so it's probably not going to get
approved
so i told the i
i told her tell national i'll pay for
the launch
a month later
chess merit badge was approved
so
so now i'm i'm there and they're
allowing me to be the first chess badge
counselor and i'm thinking oh man this
is going to be a real disaster you know
so i got like all these adults and i
made rex come and help me teach it you
know like the important part of how you
play chess okay
and so
and i was thinking we'll have a simple
ceremony right
we're talking with shannon and joy
and so it starts evolving and we decide
we're
and i thought you know what i have a
friend
who's in nasa
okay and he knows this astronaut who
used to play in outer space you know
just got out from outer space and was
playing chess
maybe he would come to the launch
so after
working with national and boy scouts and
everything else
we got him to come
and so i taught the chess merit badge
and we had both scouts from greater
great uh the council i'm with greater
great rivers and then the greater saint
louis right
and then we had fun
hey carl do you remember uh
playing in the uh i don't know i don't
have a picture of this stick horse he
was one of the
kings
no you yeah that's right you were one of
the kings and it was so much fun we got
to see chess and you know what
it went viral
randy did a little video
and every boy scout
troop in america was watching the video
about chess
and it's now
this year chess was the number two
merit badge of all merit badges offered
last year
[Applause]
now rex has done a lot of things and
wonderful things
spent a lot of our money
and
and he's there the godfather of american
chess so he was working on all these
super tournaments right
the singfield tub
the grand chess tour
getting the very very best players in
the world right
and i'm thinking okay and then the staff
is taking care of
schools right
and we're doing all these
we have a hundred chess clubs in the
greater st louis area now three of the
best colleges college chess
webster slew and
and and mizzou okay we're we're doing it
all
and i'm thinking what about the kids who
don't have coaches
we're out there with my you know my
scouts
and then i realized the barrier to
getting good at chess
was the ability to read and write it
so i
probably was the hardest book i've ever
written
you try to re write
how to read and write chess for a
seven-year-old
and i believe joy had her niece come in
and
her niece who was seven
taught her
five-year-old how to read and write
chess
so we now have it thanks to my friends
in the chess world they've taken my
little test booklet and translated it
into
eight other languages
okay so i want to point out
german was because she didn't
wait here but she didn't translate it
she found me someone in german okay i
don't have the french christian did
romania where are you alejandro did
spanish
yasser yasser's wife did dutch
wesley so's
mother helped us get a translator
where's wesley he's out there so it's
it's in filipino
right
and
i translated into indonesian
until the indonesian player from slough
read it and said
i don't know how she said it she said it
was a little rough
so basically we decided to
and then it was the best selling booklet
at the world chess hall of fame i was so
proud it sold more copies than bobby
fischer plays chess right
okay
but
[Applause]
because where the sink feels is how we
do that it is now available for free for
anybody in the world you just go to the
chess club down send it to your friends
because we're going to make chess
america the chess place and the world
chess
so we can all get better so
now reese because i'm always doing odd
things and
shannon and joy sort of figure i'm not
going to do anything new
okay this year i was on the bicentennial
commission for the state of missouri
celebrating 200 years
and i came in a little late and i looked
and they didn't have any permanent thing
that anybody was building
right for the
bicentennial so i thought a bicentennial
chess board would be
fine
so the committee went there
guess what who would i think would make
it
an eagle project right so the skeleton
who would do the work state historical
society
world chess hall of fame and the chess
club
did the funding so now the state of
missouri is going to have a 14-foot
granite chest set with 32 engravings
celebrate 200 years
of the state of missouri
and it will be in front of the capitol
and the governor has already done
as governor parsons has already we had a
small event we haven't put it down in
the ground yet to celebrate chess
so missouri is chastised
so and the final thing is i wanted to
thank all the chess lovers and the chess
players
the guys who are out there and the
people are lousy players like me
and
basically because it's been so much fun
you're actually making it possible for
us to continue
to do
and i want to thank you for this honor
and i want to tell you how appreciative
i am of being married to the
godfather of american chess
[Applause]
thank you dr singfield
much has already been said about our
next inductee
mr rex singfield and his myriad
contributions
to the resurgence of american chess
i would like to emphasize however
that supporting chess
that for the sinful supporting chess
is very much a family affair
be the establishment of the magnificent
chess club
and scholastic center of san luis
or the creation of chess events for
elite players as well as the
introduction of our wonderful game to
thousands of scholastic
uh
players
or even enhancing the culture of chess
by bringing the world chess hall of fame
to the central west end
rets and genie have always acted as
equal partners
it was in the early years of the saint
louis chess boom
that the club contacted my stepson grand
master hikaru nakamura
and offered him the position of grand
master in residence
hikaru was impressed by the genuine
warmth of the offer
decided to leave seattle to take up
residence in saint louis
he was the first super gm to do so
hikaru has asked me to express his
gratitude to rex and genie and regrets
that he is not able to attend the
ceremony tonight
one of rex's dreams has always been to
turn saint louis into the chess capital
of the usa
and he has most definitely succeeded
the same hospitality that was extended
to hikaru
was also extended to other elite players
some of those who have followed
hikaru into saint louis our grandmaster
fabiano caruana
who's here in the audience
grand master wesley soul
grandmaster linear dominguez
and most recently
grandmaster leveronian
attracting the elite is one thing
changing a culture is quite another
this is where the hall of fame comes in
in the beginning
there was one hall of fame the u.s chess
hall of fame
which over time had migrated from new
windsor to miami
in 2001
then fide vice president steve doyle
convinced the international body to
create the world chess hall of fame
and both entities were housed in the
same facility
under the sponsorship of excalibur
electronics
when excalibur was later acquired by
another company
the two halls of fame had to find a new
home
it is then that managing director al
lawrence reached out
to the chess center chess club and
scholastic center of saint louis
rex and genie singfield
loved the idea
the club was already thriving on
maryland avenue
as a popular destination for chess
players
chess players of all stripes
now here was a unique opportunity
to introduce the community
to chess culture and history as well
the sinfuls decided to purchase the
building across the street
they had it gutted
brought in an expert from new york
and redesigned the space
to house
the halls of fame and a museum
thus creating the landmark we have today
the world chess hall of fame
chess in america does not go back very
far
we certainly cannot duplicate the
history and rich heritage of european
chess
but there is something exciting
happening here in san luis right now
there is an irresistible force that is
being driven
by rex and dr jenny can singfield
it's a new history in the making
and saint louis is leading the way
[Applause]
and it gives me great pleasure
and it is with the authority vested in
me
as a trustee of the u.s chess trust
that i humbly
induct
mr rexingfield into the u.s chess hall
of fame
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
oh man
[Applause]
i thought you said you were going to
keep unruly people out of here
well thank you everyone for the gracious
applause and for attending this evening
first of all i'd like to thank my wife
jeannie for letting me start a chess
club
i really wanted to have him
[Applause]
learn to have a small place for people
in the community to play and never
dreamed of what it has become
joy and tony like to remind me that when
the club was built we had one office and
a front desk
now we have a hundred employees and
contractors
among whom my son randy is numbered that
make these organizations hum
with that being said it's the staff and
the contractors of the chess club and
world chess hall of fame that make it
all happen
[Applause]
this honor bestowed on me
really should be bestowed on them
it was i had the idea of the chess club
but i never would have imagined what it
has become
now secondly gary when i think of you
and chess
i think of a beast
see some people understand that
reference
you're the most intense person to be
around while playing chess
with that being said you are such an
eloquent speaker and connoisseur of
history and human rights
and thank you very much for your kind
and humbling remarks
sunil thank you for your thoughtful
comments
you and nicara have been friends of the
club since the beginning
to carl was the first super gm to move
to st louis which will always be a
memorable moment for me
becoming interested in chess my uncle
fred taught me how to play when i was 13
years old and i beat him the second time
we played always felt a bit guilty about
that
but i've learned to deal with the guilt
from that moment it just stuck with me i
continued to play but working family
took up time so i couldn't play many
tournaments
as most of you know bobby fischer is one
of my idols and i really wanted
chess to become more popular after the
fisher boom it did and not because of me
i've always been impressed by the ornate
and rich history
of the beautiful chess sets that people
collect and i was more than happy to
move the hall of fame from miami to st
louis so chess could be displayed in the
many formats through the incredible
exhibitions managed and created by
shannon bailey and emily allred
now this next section is kind of subtle
but extremely funny
so if you want to show how smart you are
you will react to this humor
when i first heard that i was being
inducted into the hall of fame i thought
of bob euchre the former st louis
cardinal and milwaukee brewer catcher
and current sportscaster comedian and
actor in 2003 when he was inducted into
the sports hall of fame
he said and i say fellas i really should
have gone in as a player
[Applause]
then i thought about becoming a grand
master and realized that would be too
much work so i just accept this very
humbly it's a very kind thing you're
doing thank everyone for being here
tonight and celebrating this memorable
event with me and jeannie thank you
there's some things
in life
you are happy to get to witness
and what i just got to see
and great dear friends
and great benefactors of our game they
have changed the sport they have changed
our lives they have changed my life
personally i can say i'm grateful
i will remember this moment forever
seeing you two get inducted into the
hall of fame
wonderful moment for all of us
this morning i had to wake up
whoa those are some dynamic words i must
have said
this morning i had to wake up at 4 30
a.m
why i was told
about a month ago that i would have to
do a press tour
extolling the virtues of the u.s
championship all the great players
and i said oh yeah really i got to do
that and then they said no but you also
get to talk about rex and jeannie
singfield getting inducted into the hall
of fame
okay
i can wake up for that that i'll do and
i did 25 interviews the same questions
over and over again i was in the hall of
fame they were coming to me from all
over the country and
one of the questions was tell us
about the inductees into the world chess
hall of fame into the us chess hall of
fame
and i'm thinking i only have a minute
but i did it over and over again it was
a great pleasure
thankfully we have more than a minute
for a video that has been put together
in the honor of these two now
hall of famers please
take a look at the monitor
st louis missouri
this historic city is famous for many
things
the gateway arch national park
the anheuser-busch brewery
the st louis cardinals
the blues both hockey and music
st louis also has a major distinction
from other american cities
it's the chess capital of america
and st louis boasts that distinction
because of two extraordinary people
rex and dr jeannie karen sinkfield
well i was intrigued with chess since i
was a child since i would see its
imagery in movies and i was always
wondering what is that that looks so
neat
when i was 13 i had my uncle fred
teach me how to play
and not showing my gratitude i beat him
in the second game we played always felt
a little guilty about that but not so
much guilt that i wouldn't try to do it
again and then i stayed with chess while
i was in high school at bishopenburg
high school joined the chess team stayed
very active with it then and then
continued on with it but in a
interrupted form when i entered college
at the seminary in saint louis cardinal
glennon college and then stayed with it
after i got out of the seminary and went
to st louis xu
but it wasn't ever a real formal kind of
activity for me it was you know hitting
this in and out stuff like that and then
i had these three little munchkins
running around the house
and it made it difficult to continue to
play chess because i had to leave in the
evenings or on the weekends and take
care of the kids so i told jeannie that
i'm giving up chess for a while but i
was putting her on notice that i would
come back
when the kids are grown
well the uh
the little joke i have about the chess
campus relates to rex playing chess
and years ago i said to myself yeah he
can play chess how expensive can it get
how did it all begin where was the
inspiration
well rex singfield had a lifelong hobby
and i get approached by bob jacobs who's
a big guy in the the st louis chess
scene and he says hey tony there's this
guy that really wants to start a chess
club he's retired and moved back to st
louis and
but i think you should meet him it would
be a good idea you know i've been
thinking of starting a chess club and
they said well how do we do it i said
maybe we should go around and look for
some space when i first saw the space
that the chess club was going to be and
i thought there's absolutely no way that
they can turn this into a beautiful club
you know it was uh this abandoned space
that looked like it hadn't been
renovated in years and years and they
said this is what we plan to have for
the club three stories
you know have classrooms upstairs have
free play on the main floor have a
library in the basement
we wanted to be near the schools near
the inner city schools because we wanted
to have access the whole point of this
was to get chess in front of all of the
school children in all of the schools i
became involved with the chess club
because i am the chess coach of founder
rexingfield and he started telling me
about this idea for a chess club in st
louis
and soon thereafter i was here for the
opening and wow it was the most
beautiful chess club i'd ever seen never
seen a chess club
this nice and built with obviously with
such great respect for chess and for
chess players i had to pinch myself to
make sure it wasn't in europe or russia
or somewhere else
all the details down to everything the
chairs the tables the weighted chess
pieces
everywhere you look it was an homage
to the vision of chess
and our noble game
and as everyone who has ever been here
has always been very impressed with the
club it's it's become a worldwide
phenomenon
the u.s chess championships for men and
women needed a home
and there was really only one solution
rex was meeting with randy bauer randy
bauer's been very involved with the u.s
chess federation for a number of years
so i tell them well we're building a
chess club why don't you come and see
the build-out as we're walking from the
racquet club over to this location
i said to him you know someday i would
love to be able to host a u.s
championship here in st louis and he
goes well it just so happens they're
looking for a sponsor so you might be
the one and that's exactly what happened
that's it came together that fast so we
made a bid and we got it and uh it's a
pretty remarkable and the way it has
grown
is astounded everyone certainly
astounded me more than anyone i never
expected it to turn into what it has
become a world power in chess
here in st louis you have a professional
championship you have the best players
in the world you
everyone everything is taken care of and
everyone is looked after and i think
that's that's very important towards um
professionalizing the game of chess and
and making it more unpopular for the
general public i definitely think the
bar has been raised for u.s women's
chess i think the the
status of this championship
has has definitely given something for
the players to reach higher for
you know just knowing that every year
there's this
very strong tournament
um it's going to be broadcast to
thousands of people across the country
and across the world with big prizes it
gives you something to train for and of
course now it's a very prestigious title
like with this championship title and
now you can say like you're definitely a
very top player well obviously after the
that first experience i hope that it
would continue to be here and
then it it did so i was very happy and
then after you know one or two years it
seemed like i mean there's really no
other place that it should be held this
was by far the best
experience i've had playing chess in the
united states so now i just you know i
assume it's going to be here for i don't
know for the foreseeable future
basically
how do you foster and build interest in
the game of chess in america
again rex and genie had a plan
scholastic chess has always been very
important to us since the very beginning
you know when the club opened we worked
with a local non-profit called urban
future and frank van brie really helped
kind of mold inform what the scholastic
program was going to become in the early
days it was kind of tough getting chess
in schools
as you know it's very tough for a lot of
teachers to give up some of their class
time for something especially like chess
when they feel like they're already
stretched thin as it is
so
it took a number of years before we were
really able to kind of get our foot in
the door at a lot of schools before
teachers started talking to each other
and explaining to each other just what
they were seeing because of the chess
programs now we have exactly the
opposite problem it's almost too hard to
keep up really the mission of the club
is to foster the game of chess and all
the educational benefits
it can generate especially to children
we're in well over 100 schools
and we're we've got
in-school programs part of the regular
curriculum and after school programs as
the children's you get more interested
and they have their friends come and
play you know that we see with these
huge scholastic tournaments they have
you know thousands of kids playing
so that is what is the resurgence in
chess
and thankfulness it's very important
there's no doubt that there's a
correlation between how our kids perform
in chess and how they perform in
scholastics and what it does is it it
helps engage learners
they
enjoy doing chess it it makes them
becoming more more analytical more
disciplined in terms of how they
approach their studies in school overall
it gives them something to look forward
to as we've seen with surveys that were
done
kids that have chess in school look
forward to it and they also become
better students
in and outside the classroom as well
we've started a program where we're
teaching the police officers how to
teach chess to school so the police are
now going into schools
in an entirely different setting they're
going in there as chess teachers what
this does is not only helps build the
you know self-esteem of the student of
the at-risk youth also help them
with discipline and other things but it
does
promote a better relationship between
the police department and the community
the police department serves
the chess
merit badge for the boy scouts the
detective detective rick metz who's
driving me today on my security detail
his son received a chess
merit patch and i said well do you know
who
whose idea the chess merit bed was he
said who's
and i said genie singfields he goes wow
i had no idea when we
talked natural into doing the chess
merit badge i threw out that we would do
a lodge
next thing we know we have these two boy
scout you know groups
and grand masters in the super giant
chess set and astronauts
they were fired up in five years 170 000
boys are in the merit match
they have to teach two other boys who
are talking about over half a million
kids now know how to play chess
and so they they are touching a lot of
lives in a
whole lot of different ways they they
make a big difference in a lot of
people's lives and in
the overall
community as well it also gives us
something to be
proud of it builds civic pride we are
the chess capital of the united states
of america
in 2009 another chess opportunity was
brewing far south of missouri in the
sunshine state
again rex and genie were ready well the
world chess hall of fame which was
housed in florida at that time
after being previously housed in d.c in
new york was having trouble
getting funding from its supporters
and they had raised the issue could
somebody else take it so aaron lawrence
called me and said would st louis
consider taking it
and could they consider supporting it
and i said in a heartbeat i'll send a
team i'll get you to talking to joy bray
and you guys can figure out what we need
to do
and as you know from looking at it today
back then was a microcosm of what it has
become
it's a full-scale
artful
museum
and it's impressive what they've done we
rotate the show several times a year
we've had exhibits which
i don't think any other chess museum in
the world
would be able to have or certainly has
never had
so we've been very lucky in that regard
and it's basically all due to the
tremendous staff that we had and the
opportunity that was thrown our way
today
chess in america is much stronger
millions of people have been affected by
the st louis chess club and the world
chess hall of fame and museum
this is our chance to say thank you rex
and genie
we appreciate you and all you've done
for us
[Music]
that was an extraordinary video i got to
tell you
uh i noticed some things
first of all little ray-ray
turned into ray robson yeah i was cute
as ever
uh jennifer shahadi i'm sorry jen
couldn't be here we miss her so much
saw carol jarecki as well who since
passed on such a great friend to the
club we have
some of us grown up here
some of us have grown a little older
here i started with hair i remember
but wow what a transformation i do
remember tony rich
taking me on a tour off the club when it
looked like crap
just that picture you saw and he said
it's gonna be a great chess club here
and i was like okay
good luck
and it's a miracle it has really been a
miracle and that video really showed it
uh we've been a family we've grown up
like a family and it was in fact family
who put that together with spectrum
studios i'd like to introduce the son of
dr gene
and rexingfield
the president as i said randy singfield
[Applause]
well uh
so good to be here first of all i want
to thank my team and at spectrum studios
as well as the team at silverback for
putting this video together on such
short order
uh it turned out great and it's
[Applause]
it was just such a wonderful trip down
memory lane you know so many fond
memories come back watching that again
so
thanks team
mom
dad
congratulations
congratulations and thank you
thank you for being two of the best
parents any son could ever ask for
[Applause]
dad i especially want to thank you for
dropping out of the seminary
that worked out pretty well for me hub
solid move
um
mom i
i don't even know where to start um
the things that you and dad have done
and affected
so many people
if i had to pinpoint one thing i would i
would
think it's your
your dedication to scouting that i want
to thank you the most for
not only did you push me to become an
equal scout reluctantly
at an early age of 14
you've devoted
30 plus years of your life to scouting
and have affected so many
of our nation's youth and
our nation's future leaders so
thank you and congratulations for
everything you do for boy scouts
[Applause]
dad you mentioned feeling being awkward
uh about being inducted into the hall of
fame um
since you're not a grand master as most
most people inducted to the hall of
famer grand masters but
with everything that you've done for
chess in america i i think that you are
more deserving
um and mom you as well you're both very
deserving of this great honor and i
think everyone in this room will agree
with me
[Applause]
thank you for everything that you have
done for the chess community and the
community as a whole
your hard work determination and
generosity know no bounds
the number of people of whose lives you
have
affected with that generosity is
astonishing
um
i think just about everyone in this room
feels the same way
dad a lot of people call you the
godfather of chess
but mom and dad
collectively
i like to think of you as the saints of
saint louis chess
congratulations on your induction i love
you both very much
i wish i could get my son to say that
all right well
it's time for
the players
and the reason we're here for the next
couple of weeks will be because we have
some of the finest players
not only in the country but even on a
worldwide stage us chess has become all
of that
we didn't used to be able to say that
we had some great players uh yasser 01
comes to mind used to represent back in
the day but yes this lineup is a
powerhouse this is scary the players we
have playing in these events now and to
bring those players to the stage to talk
about them we're going to bring the big
dog who's been here since the very
beginning executive director of the
saint louis chess club tony rich
thanks maurice yeah and following that
randy man yeah i think you had us all in
tears here
you know a lot of people have talked
let me start off i've got work to do i
need to go over there and and bring the
players up and ask them to pick a number
and all that kind of stuff and we're
going to get to that in just a moment
but i wanted to to express my gratitude
and thankfulness to both jeannie and rex
as well
it's not just the top players
in the country or the top players in the
world it's not just the
tens of thousands of scholastic chess
players that have learned the game
because of you guys it's not just the
fact that america knows chess more now
than it ever has
it's not just the fact that you've
provided opportunities for
promising young players who want to
become these grandmasters and play in
the u.s championships or even the
players that are really on the cusp of
becoming world-class players too
i think gary said it best whenever he
said you know you don't just focus on
one area of the game you focus on the
young scholastic players you focus on
scouts you focus on women in chess you
focus on
being able to read and write chess just
the basic vocabulary of understanding
the game as well
rex you joke that you you know kind of
fell into this and didn't have the the
vision for what the chess club could
become or what what we would be doing
and none of us did in fact 14 years ago
this month we sat at oh bistro in the
chase park plaza hotel had our very
first dinner where we talked about the
club and that's really kind of the
impetus of of where it all
began
but
over those past 14 years you've both
provided guidance and direction and
support financial support yes but more
importantly um
[Music]
your your trust your faith that that all
of the staff at the chess club in the
world chess hall of fame could execute a
plan and and bring chess to american
ways that we've never seen before so
personally my life has been changed just
like marie's just like the 50 other
employees at the chess club and just
like so many other folks who none of us
will ever know so thank you again genie
and rex
so now the work part of my my job begins
uh chess tournaments are played in lots
of different formats this particular
event the u.s championship in the u.s
women's championship uh of late we've
been holding as round robin tournaments
that's an event in which all of the
players compete against all of the other
players in the same tournament
accumulate points as they go along and
the person with the most points at the
end wins so in order to determine the
order in which the players face each
other and with which color we have to
draw lots the players will be invited up
to the stage we have some lovely gifts
for them over here they're belts with a
nice chest belt buckle on them um and
we'll ask the players to come up they'll
pick one of their gifts and they'll get
their pairing number from there at the
very end i'll announce all the pairings
for round one which begins tomorrow at
one o'clock at the chess club if you
can't attend in person always remember
you can follow us on uschestjams.com
our amazing commentary team this year
i'm so excited we have grand masters
yasser sarawan christian carrillo and
none other than maurice ashley calling
all the play-by-play action if you
haven't heard them do commentary on
chess tune in for 10 minutes just watch
some of it i swear you'll be a convert
you'll love chess after that
i'm also very thankful to have an
amazing arbiting team here with us
you know you saw carol joracki earlier
who unfortunately passed away
during the pandemic
carol was kind of my guiding light when
it came to being an arbiter i remember
in 2009 when she came to st louis and
she was the chief arbor of the us and
u.s women's championship chris byrd was
one of the deputy arbiters and i i was
the other one and carol would sit down
with us and she was no nonsense i
remember her
she had a feed a handbook you know it's
this little booklet something like this
and she opened the page she had it like
memorized she opened the page and she
said tony this is how you do chess norms
i want you to sit down and calculate
every norm that could happen in the
tournament by hand i want you to figure
out if anybody is going to get an
international master norm or a grand
master norm and i tell you i have never
sweat so much for any test in my entire
life
carol will truly be missed but our
arbiting team that we have here
are more than capable of carrying that
that mantle and doing a wonderful job
our chief arbiter for the u.s
championship i'm sorry as i call you
guys if you would come up and help me
with the drawing of lots as well our
chief arbiter of the u.s championship is
international arbiter frank guadalupe
[Applause]
our chief arbiter for the u.s women's
championship is international arbiter
chris byrd
[Applause]
and our deputy chief arbiter for both
events combined is maya myers
so maurice is going to come up here and
he's going to call off the players names
uh this uh brain trust over here and i
we're going to
make sure the players get their pairing
numbers and at the very end we will tell
you what the round one pairings will be
so maurice
thank you tony well this is what the
players have been waiting on
and so let's get started we're going to
start with the u.s women's championships
i counted 15
championship titles
in the women's event 15 one player
accounting for eight
which is pretty remarkable
in and of itself but we will start in
reverse order and to pick first will be
women's international master megan lee
[Applause]
[Music]
number six
next up women's international math
master asharitha eswaran
[Music]
[Applause]
number one
next up woman's grandmaster and former
champ sabina foyser
[Applause]
[Music]
number 11.
next up women's grandmaster anna
schadevich
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number 12.
next up women's grandmaster talia
cervantes
[Music]
number four
next up women's grandmaster katarina
nemtsova
[Applause]
[Music]
number three
next up a name i will mispronounce many
times over the broadcast women's grand
master guruk
jonova talk here to jonova i think it is
more or less
not
uh would you mind please say your name
once for everybody correctly
yes full name please hi
my full name is
vegan
i missed it by this much
yeah so you're going to screw that up
many times so don't even try it she says
she goes by beg him though so we're
going to do that
number eight
next up two-time champion and returning
once again to the championship nazi
paikitzy
[Applause]
[Music]
number two
next up women's grandmaster tatev
abrahamian
[Applause]
[Music]
number five
next up
four-time champion
international master anna zatonski
[Applause]
[Music]
number 10.
next up international master carissa yep
[Applause]
[Music]
number nine and to do the final honors
one of the legends of
us women's chess
an eight-time champion grandmaster irina
crush
[Applause]
lucky number seven let's see if it's
lucky for her as she goes after a
record-tying
ninth championship
simply remarkable
pairings are being calculated and
tabulated there we will now go to the
championship field
[Music]
and we have
grand master
john burke
[Applause]
[Music]
number nine
next up grand master daniel naraditsky
[Applause]
number
11. next up grandmaster alex lenderman
[Applause]
number five
next up
first time in the championship grand
master lazaro bruzon
[Applause]
[Music]
number seven
next up grandmaster sam savion
[Applause]
number one
next up grand master darius spheres
[Applause]
[Music]
number four
next up little ray ray grand master ray
robson
[Applause]
number two
i mentioned that there were 15
titles in the women's section it's so
difficult in the men's section extremely
competitive there are only four total
titles in the men's side will be very
hotly contested one of them
goes to
the one next up grandmaster i should say
went to grandmaster sam shankland
[Applause]
number 12.
next up grandmaster jeffrey zhang
[Applause]
number three
next up grandmaster lenier dominguez
[Applause]
number eight
next up a two-time champion grandmaster
wesley so
he happens to also be the reigning
champion
[Applause]
[Music]
number 10
and finally he's the world number two
he's only stole one of the us
championship titles however he'll
certainly be looking to make it a second
the world number two player grandmaster
fabiano caruana
[Applause]
number six
we've got our calculations our
tabulations pairings ready tony
come and announce the pairings for round
one
it's a very dangerous job i just checked
with my arbiters and i said do you want
to double check the pairings before i
announce it and they're like yes
but but here we go
in the u.s women's championship tomorrow
starting at 1 pm we will have a shritha
esvaran versus ana shravich
nazi pekidzi versus sabina feuzer
katerina nem sova versus anna zatonski
maybe i should have oh i'm sorry talia
cervantes against carissa yip
tatev abrahamian versus gora begim tohir
nova
megan lee versus irina crush in the u.s
championship section sam savion versus
sam shanklin ray robson versus daniel
naraditsky jeffrey zhong versus wesley
so
daria spirits against john burke alex
lenderman faces off against lenio
dominguez and fabiano cariawana will
have white against lazaro bruzan good
luck to all the players tomorrow
[Applause]
well folks we have come to the end of
our evening
uh
it is going to be a very exciting event
to be sure
you should tune in tomorrow
it will start at 12 50 central that's
150 on the east coast very exciting
chess we'll be doing commentary for the
show i've been told there are lots of
goodies you've got to get they're mass
books read and write chess books tote
bags lapel pins all courtesy of cue
boutique take free stuff it's always
good when they tell you you can take
free stuff take it everyone thank you so
much for joining us for the 2021 u.s
championship opening ceremony and the
inductions into the chess hall of fame
enjoy the evening good night
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you